corona alarm in der groß schlachterei
westfleisch in coesfeld mehr als 260
beschäftigte sind infiziert der laden
ist seit freitag dicht vor den
unterkünften der leiharbeiter aus
rumänien sind zäune mit wachpersonal
aufgestellt damit sie die quarantäne
einhalten
aktuell lasse das
nrw-gesundheitsministerium landesweit
alle der rund 20.000 mitarbeiter von
fleischfabriken auf corona testen
gleiches solle niedersachsen passieren
auch in anderen bundesländern gibt es
corona ausbrüche in schlachthöfen in
schleswig holstein wurden 109
fleischfabrik mitarbeiter positiv
getestet in baden württemberg bei müller
fleisch sogar 400 und nun schalten wir
nach coesfeld und zwar direkt vor einer
unterkunft steht mein kollege celal
sciacca guten abend
du warst heute in diesen unterkünften
wie genau sieht es dort tatsächlich aus
ja das bild das wir heute zu sehen
bekommen haben das war mit sicherheit
leicht verzerrt das muss man definitiv
sagen in den letzten tagen sind viele
mitarbeiter vom gesundheitsamt in diese
unterkünfte reingegangen haben
kontrolliert haben betten teilweise
auseinander geschoben dass diese
mindestabstände eingehalten werden fakt
ist trotzdem dass in diesen unterkünften
mindestens zehn leute gemeinsam unter
einem dach leben und auch unter anderem
einer krone infizierte gemeinsam mit
noch negativ getesteten ja am esstisch
sitzen dass sie gemeinsam die gleiche
toilette benutzen
und da versucht jetzt hier der kreis
einzugreifen
plakate aufgehangen hat wir sind
reaktions mittel bereitgestellt aber ist
es immer noch problematisch dass die
menschen unter einem dach zusammenleben
das heißt die hygienischen zustände sind
wirklich schwierig haben denn die
arbeiter vor ort angst vor corona es ist
zwiespältig auf der einen seite
natürlich haben die menschen angst um
ihre gesundheit aber das was sich mir
gezeigt hat ist dass die menschen
hauptsächlich angst um ihre existenz
haben sie sind hierhergekommen aus
osteuropa und geld zu verdienen um geld
in ihre heimat schicken zu können das
fällt jetzt erst mal flach ein bewohner
der unterkunft hinter mir sagte noch
wohin am fünfzehnten soll der lohn
kommen was danach passieren wird ist
noch nicht geklärt
dementsprechend verhalten sie sich auch
ich habe hier in der unterkunft hinten
wird dieses man sieht hinter dem
umzäunten bereich laufen die menschen
teilweise immer noch rum dass die
quarantäne regeln das isolations regeln
wirklich ernst genommen werden das
konnte ich auf jeden fall hier nicht
beobachten den herzlichen dank schiller
als acker und nun schalten wir auch
gleich weiter und zwar in baden
württemberg sind rund 1000 leiharbeiter
von müller fleisch in arbeits quarantäne
und unser reporter sascha baumann ist
vor ort sascha wie genau ist die
situation was sagen die behörden
ja ich konnte mit bastian rosenau dem
landrat hier immens kreis sprechen und
er sagte mir dass der betrieb kurz vor
der kompletten schließung stand wenn man
die infektionszahlen nicht so schnell in
den griff bekommen hätte
es waren ja zunächst von 1000
mitarbeitern 330 infiziert man dann eine
zweite testreihe gemacht dort waren es
dann noch einmal 85 und ja er sagt ganz
klar in denen die meist osteuropäischen
mitarbeitende brachte wie er ist sagt
vielen herzlichen dank sascha baumann
nach pforzheim
und es geht direkt weiter und zwar zu
clemens tönnies
er ist deutschlands oberster fleisch
boss miteigentümer der turniers holding
guten abend herr tönnies so viele corona
fälle in schlachtfeldern schlachthöfen
warum gerade sind diese schlachthöfe
betroffen was glauben sie wie erklären
sie sich das ja nun das ist ja einmal
ein bereich wo die mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter sehr eng stehen
dort muss man aufpassen dort muss man
mit konzepten und strategien in einer
pandemie zeit natürlich die die
infektionsketten unterbrechen erkennen
unterbrechen und dann kann man dieses
risiko drastisch minimieren sie haben
gerade gesagt und wir haben es ja gerade
auch schon gesehen die menschen die dort
arbeiten in den schlachthöfen arbeiten
sehr aneinander zum teil arbeit zum teil
schlafen sie ja auch in
sammelunterkünften das heißt glauben sie
dass zum teil auch die hygiene
wirklichen grund dafür ist da sind wir
ziemlich intensiv hinterher das heißt
also wir können natürlich nicht jedem
mitarbeiter in den kühlschrank gucken
aber wir sind intensiv dran mit
ermahnungen und immer wieder neuen
sports und so weiter auch dort die
hygiene einzuhalten sehr sehr wichtig
hat handys wenn man jetzt so diese
nachrichten hört auch darüber dass es
immer mehr corona fälle in schlachthöfen
gibt ist das vielleicht auch ein grund
warum man gerade vielleicht aus fleisch
essen verzichten sollte das fleisch ist
ja gut fürs immunsystem das jetzt zu
meiden ist ja genau falsch rum wir
müssen ja unser immunsystem stärken
wir haben einen versorgungsauftrag und
dem kommen wir nach niemals zu lasten
der gesundheit unserer mitarbeiterinnen
und mitarbeiter oder auch einer pandemie
gefährdung
ich bin überzeugt davon dass wir es gut
gemacht haben bisher das bedeutet nicht
dass nichts passieren kann wir müssen
weiterhin auf der hut sein wir müssen
konsequent die gene einhalten